i JD berry the acting returning officer
for Darby south constituency hereby
publish and declare that the total
number of votes given for each candidate
that the said election is as follows
Margaret Mary Beckett Labour Party
26,000 430 Allen Lane graves you pip
2011 her gender sing NATO Liberal
Democrat 1229 Ian Christopher Simone at
the Green Party 454 Yvonne Williams the
Conservative Party candidate 15 thousand
182 I can confirm that Margaret Mary
Beckett is this day duly elected member
of parliament for the derby-style
constituents faces
I also hereby publish and declare that
the number of ballot papers rejected and
not counted by me is as follows one of
official mark zero voting for more than
one candidate 33 writing or mark by
which a voter could be identified two
unmarked or wholly void or insurgency 17
thank you I want to say thank you very
much to the returning officer and all
her staff and to all the people who
worked so hard to actually deliver these
results here this evening the counting
agents the staff of the arena and so on
and I also want to particularly thank
the tremendously hard-working team
they've helped to produce this results
particularly my agent James shires but
all the many volunteers and helpers who
came and helped make this possible but I
hope no one will mind if I say that the
people who of course Susan I'm most
grateful are the electorate of Darby
south thank you for putting your
confidence in me once again but I will
do my utmost never to let you down
thank you very much
[Applause]